then question with a thousand balls
how to choose your political party
in any case we agree on this
there are many political parties
so it's very difficult to see
clear and to find yourself in there
the main starting point
is to agree with the
great ideas that are defended by the party
and then you have to take into account two things
the national and local levels
therefore at the national level
we look at the ideas that are defended by the party
as I told you
for that we also look at the history of the party
where it comes from
who who what created who created him
what it has already brought in the past
and then great figures
because often
we identify with people
who have fights that resemble us
and that touch us
so be careful
what to keep in mind too
is that we can disagree
with everything the party says
or whatever the people of a party say
because in every part
there are different currents of ideas
and then in my opinion
it is also necessary to look at the local level
it's what mattered the most to me
you look at your city who are the elected officials
uh the activists looking on the stands
by going to City Council
by looking on social networks
and you meet these people
because at first it's staff
you will
work with them and make your ideas with them